nel film disney aladdin qual è la nome
della scimmietta non ho mai visto da
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono felice ed oggi siamo tornati su
trivia crack e altre droghe ma
seriamente a basta
ma basta contro nicole ciao nicola
completa la canzone musica e canto
proprio scelto un argomento in cui sono
super ferrato guardate come butto sto
euro e 06 centese imporre a perfetto la
pausini le so proprio tutte cazzo ma la
pausini non ha fatto un pezzo con martin
garri io dovrei completare con la parola
dopo irraggiungibile da sorella [ __ ]
e non della pausini è solo dicendo in
generale della cantina di un palazzo nei
lo zecchino d'oro ma cristo nella
cantina di un palazzo nei tutti i
gattini senza padrone organizzarono una
gara di pallone un comitato una riunione
che è bello che non sono cazzo dello
zecchino d'oro vivo ogni secondo come
l'ultimo secondo credi in poche cose ma
ci credo fino in fondo si cazzola moroso
l'amoroso alessandra ma chi la guarda
che fanno che c'hai 4 scesi al bano tra
tutti il cazzo di cantanti ma proprio al
bano ma cristo felicità e tenersi per
mano andare in onda questo lo so però
presi per mano da re lontano la felicità
e ammazzare una nonna con la sua gamma
alla felicità anche se fuori fra fede e
fedex tutto è magnifico e magnifico 4
giusta è incredibile io non so un cazzo
di musica italiana 4 giuste lasciami
sognare lasciami dimenticare se
alessandra di vichy capire che c'è io
devo cantare posto tuo e ballavo a piedi
sporchi
viva i feticisti e cantavo a piedi nudi
c'è chi canta st 9 ballava piedi nudi
cantavo a piedi nudi mi sembra un pò
strano prendere a morsi posso credere
che bruciare culo ma come cazzo ha fatto
no va bene questa assurda
raga all ultima va bene è mica in
inglese baby the night ease non lo so on
fire burning burning che l'aveva seccate
tutto fino all'ultimo [ __ ] l'aveva
azzeccate tutte senza saperne una fino
all'ultima poi mica svegliato con
zucchero arca ignote io prendo solo
quello di cannes
se l'avete capita e posso suicidarmi
poteva farmi la domanda chi canta e cioè
maroni pieni che quella la sapevo
youtube italia contro martina ciao
martina che il nome adatto yotobi alla
serie video di video che ha fatto per un
po dopo che ha smesso di fare mostarda
quale youtube era lavorato per anni alla
rai
gli 8 bit e tutte su youtube son karim
stai colonizzando st applicazione bella
tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti in questo
nuovo video io sono vari j vegas anima o
sterni benfica una foto noi o fa vigente
2 a 1 per gli ottavi chi è il fondatore
di me la godo geni più piazza a chi di
questi youtuber piace rompere i piatti
fa vj anni sasha perché ti piace rompere
i piatti spiegamelo non ho mai capito
anima questa maniera ma il pro giuro che
anche sul set di social peso di tanto
andali spaccava non so perché non lo
inviterò mai a casa penso quale cover
hanno cantato insieme
sapete che non so nominarne neanche
mezzo muri muri e muriel blu boom e luca
vabbè minchia ho risposto così perché la
sapevo vi giuro è come si chiamano i
proprietari del canale i soldi spicci
oddio amatevi genoa non andrè claudio
andrea me lo ricordavo dal camion
surreal power dove abita ora a luglio
2016 luglio quindi mese scorso milano
finisci questa celebre frase ron e sexy
porco dalla mappa vj no ma che cazzo
vuol dire tranne sexy parigino chi è
sopra nominato lo youtuber barbuto yo yo
marcus chrome che gioco non ha mai
portato giochi ma non lo posso sapere
chi fa clay 1 è guasto e gli altri la fa
la fatti anche mia nonna quindi viene
soprannominato il re delle banane
smith ex quali tra questi youtuber non
sono imparentati surreale vegas anche
the surreal porca [ __ ] e anche del
surrealista e colonizzando st puntata
chi ha scritto ma basta azzurri che
cazzo tante domande e sussurri al power
in un minuto e ha scritto la canzone
surreali per quando studi al power ha
raggiunto un milione di iscritti
masarone che culo chi ha fatto il video
punto di vista in famiglia
no
regatano scusate ragazzi non l'ho visto
o si può che non si può che alice balla
da gli spieghiamo alice ma basta ogni
tre secondi ma cazzo che tipo è il
pokémon ha già è vero minchia le nuove
generazioni non so niente luna la
ragazzi io vi sto gioco c'è un culo
devastante che generazione nato misma gu
misma gius mi pare fosse nella quarta
andato un po a ragionamento ma non la
sapevo con precisione vabbè che animali
sono i duran duran duran che la fa
formiche ho cambiato all'ultimo era volo
metter scarafaggi non lo sapevo secondo
il pokédex porca altun char izard questa
è la domanda sulle vecchie generazioni e
dell'unica che cannero di brutto nuncia
results era alto due metri
non e 70 so più alto io di un charlie
sanchis harder mica l'infanzia rovinata
e che pensavo fosse un flessione di 2
metri con i cia risate mi arriva tipo
qua la spalla piccole non vuoi scoprire
di più certo mi chiami ai propri
interessato st pubblicità cartoni
animati cartoni animati dai facciamo
cartoni animati ci siamo ragazzi giorgio
vanni sarà fiero di me in dragon ball z
chi taglia la coda vegeta trasformato in
oggiaro durante la battaglia tra lui e
goku creevy crilin giorgio vanni non ha
visto questa parte giorgio vanni guarda
il video da questo momento in poi la
prossima domanda sarà molto difficile ma
[ __ ] di che cosa è ghiotta doremi
varin chiado re mi metti la mano qui
doremi le piace il pesce quindi sushi
bistecche doremi non è un cartone per
vegani [ __ ] sti tune eures 06 06
cosa te ne fai di quei sei centesimi
teli figli tutti bene bene nel curva fra
rispondere alle domande della disney
qual è stato il primo lungometraggio
animato della disney cenerentola
come no a caso è vero che pirla ero
convintissimo fosse cenerentola dai li
faccio rifaccio quale di questi film di
principesse disney è il più vecchio
biancaneve
abbiamo detto prima il primo nel film
disney aladdin
qual è la nome della scimmietta non ho
mai visto non lo so vi giuro non lo so
non lo sapevo non lo so devo rimedierò
promesso simba il protagonista di quale
film disney
non lo so sto scherzando v7 cagati un po
addosso vera quando è stata fondata la
walt disney company che culo quale
famoso film disney contiene un orso
chiamato ball un libro della giungla
anche questo l'ho visto è come si
chiamava il famoso granchietto nel
cartone disney la cena la sirenetta
sebastien sebastien sebastian porca
[ __ ] entra ragazzi ho perso dovete
andare a morire e basta grazie per
avermi fatto spendere altri un euro e 06
per venti volte va bene va bene ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto un mi piace
per farmi guardare alla di fatemi sapere
se ne volete altri se ne volete altri
ovviamente sfilate mi perché sto facendo
così in tre secondi che non sto
indicando un cazzo che giorno si
tracciato momento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come intende
schizzi anni sono saliti di scrittrici
rimediavano proseguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]